um you mentioned earlier that like there
was a certain point in time where
you said Uzi carti you're not getting
these interviews I remember that really
nobody is but well you're right right
yeah um that's that's a fair point like
big boy probably get cardi B
um oh I'm in Playboy cardi but yeah oh
cardi well yeah
you never did Playboy cardi ever he came
to the studio and stuff uh when we were
still downtown and like I remember I
even had a conversation with him at a
concert and or a show rather in like
2015 2016 where I was like bro let's do
this interview and I remember he was
like I ain't trying to do no long [__]
I'll do a 20 minute joint I did like a
20 minute interview with him at the
radio station and it was horrible it was
horrible it's on YouTube it was like
talking to like a piece of drywall right
if you watch that big boy interview you
did it was [__] the worst thing ever
but yeah I mean like it's always weird
with [__] like that where it's like [__]
if I just tried a little bit harder I
could have a Playboy Card interview from
2016. that's [__] crazy but I
probably have like [__] 30 million
views or something I probably did like
you know a million other interviews that
were easier to get instead of working on
that one that was like well I was gonna
say like obviously you have a huge
platform you still have a very important
platform but there was an era in which
your platform was literally you had a
[__] record deal your platform was
like a career maker for up and coming
artists and because like 2016 there were
so few options for an artist like the
perfect example of it is six nine like I
met six nine in 2017 or some [__] and
then he proceeded to harass the [__] out
of me
for like six months or eight months or
some [__] trying to get an interview and
then finally he did the song with trippy
which I felt was like oh okay he's
actually becoming a real thing so I did
the interview with him but if that was
his first like song that really like
actually did yeah yeah and uh but but I
remember I showed that to Hell Rel and
he wasn't feeling it at the time but uh
you know
six nine had to go to somebody like me
to try to get an interview where I was
like even right now in New York I can
think of like eight different platforms
that he could go [__] with if you're on
the radar or yeah yeah it's like there's
so many different people that you could
[__] with whereas now like if I I I I
get a lot of hate for like oh you
changed your [__] up and didn't just
keep doing underground artist interviews
what I think people don't realize is
that no jumper as a business would never
have lasted in the long run if I just
kept doing only underground rapper
interviews like building out casts and
hosts and expanding into doing
interviews with Comedians and YouTubers
and porn stars and whoever like I needed
to do all that [__] in order to like
keep the boat afloat you know because
the the media space just became so
flooded so fast and even especially now
where everybody wants to get paid for
interviews and [__] I mean like like in
terms of like really ambitious ones no
for sure no I'm not sure to crack me for
like 10 grand and I laughed I literally
said LOL I'll pass
so what that is amazing yeah no I get
hit with that all the time when people
want five or ten Grand who are like have
no business asking for money and I'm
just like wow the game is [__] up but
I was gonna say like because like you
said like you did you I mean obviously
everyone should evolve and the business
model for you has evolved
um but I remember like even talking to
like
you go back to that 2017-2018 era of no
jumper I remember talking to Sasha who I
think you would were talking to at a
certain point time maybe doing a no
jumper Festival
um you had the single you were you were
so dived in on the music do you remember
was there like a point in time or a
moment that you can kind of point to
where you were like I gotta be more than
this if this is gonna really last I
guess I've just always been like doing
everything I could possibly do to try to
keep the brand going and keep the brand
afloat and keep content going and just
figuring out how I could make content on
a regular basis that would do well with
the audience and stuff and so yeah I
mean definitely me getting canceled in
2018 was probably the biggest factor in
terms of like oh now you have some
percentage of artists that are not going
to want to [__] with you because they're
on some work because they have this
perception of whatever happens that's
when you lost your deal with Atlantic
right exactly and they in even like you
know the the it might not be them but
like oh they got a manager and this
manager is trying to scare them out of
working with us because of the fact that
um I've got my own [__] or whatever
so I think that was definitely one
moment where it became like oh you're
gonna have to really figure this [__]
out because maybe your initial game plan
is not is like a little simple it's not
going to work out necessarily if you
just stay focused on just talking to
these underground rappers you know and I
always just I I always was ambitious in
the sense of just wanting to talk to
everybody and sometimes I do go back in
time and think like well what if I had
just interviewed the cool up and coming
rappers and I just kept my [__] super
selective I think the brand in terms of
its coolness might have
persevered like it would have seemed
cooler or like more of a honor more
exclusive but at the same time like I
just felt like all of these competitors
springing up all around us and it was
like I just I'm not going to be able to
just do this underground rapper thing
forever because even back in 2018
I could feel that it was slowing down
pretty dramatically in the i in the
sense of like 2015 2016 2017 there was a
new underground rapper every [__] day
it was also like an era of SoundCloud
and Underground Music that was like not
being represented I guess yeah as to
where and and like the IG blogs hadn't
really taken all the way over yeah
yeah I mean now it's just there's just
so much [__] that's it's tough to stand
out and like a lot of the best content
that I do now is just bringing
interesting personalities together
whether it's like the consistent
personalities on the channel or you know
like yesterday I had a Destiny the
twitch streamer with dude and whack 100.
who would have thought them two would
ever sit down like I was so happy I was
just geeked up off that just like I
cannot believe that I just brought these
two [__] together and you know
I'm always just kind of trying to think
of stuff that'll be interesting for
people like that because you just don't
have a new trippy red or a new little
Uzi or a new X to talk to every week you
might get a couple of those a year but
it just doesn't you know they just don't
happen that often yeah it's crazy
because if you think of like a I I think
it's something like your early
relationships with guys like x with
juice world you know when juicer was
alive obviously um Legend has there has
there been any of those relationships
that you carried into 2022 or 2023 where
you're like
maybe this person switched up a little
like I can't get this person on my
platform even though I was there with
them at the studio or going to you know
all the time yeah like I hear Vlad talk
about that all the time how he was the
first person to Amigos interview yeah
but I feel like that's different though
I feel like it's different though
because I feel like you actually like
were were with these guys like I
remember seeing your Vlogs or you'd be
at shows like you actually were like
hanging out doing drugs with guys but
like all the dudes early on that I had
these strong relationships with are dead
pretty much I was gonna say they most of
them passed away yeah and even by the
time you get to like 2018 or 2019 I
think of like oh I did Jack Harlow
interview when he wasn't really on and
that I assume has a lot of views and
it's like pretty sick that I got a jack
Harlow interview early on but it's also
like I hung out with Jack Harlow for
five minutes before we did the interview
and then we did the interview and then I
hung out with them for five minutes
afterwards and then I never saw him
again after that I just I don't build
these crazy strong friendships with the
artists in the way that I used to which
sometimes I look at people like you who
I feel like you do really good with the
relationship side of things because
you're in the clubs and you're booking
these dudes and you end with the radius
is a really good way to like maintain
these relationships and stuff and a lot
of the people that I look at that I kind
of have regrets it's like you know how
did I get a suicide boys interview with
millions and millions of views and then
I never went out of my way to hang out
with them ever again after that even
though I got this crazy piece of content
super early in their career and it's
really because I was just focused on the
next thing and like you know sometimes I
regret that I didn't do more to like
nurture relationships but also it just
feels like there's so many potential
relationships because of the fact that I
just interviewed so many [__] people
and I'm so busy that you know that's one
thing I miss about the stores that I
would just have a lot more like casual
interactions with people and it was just
kind of happening All Around Me whereas
now it's like I really kind of rely on
my publicist or dming people to to get
content going yeah you're because you're
also not like going out like you to at
all I haven't been out like I used to
see I used to see you and your girl at
[__] all the time concerts [__]
festivals whatever oh what's up guys
like Saturday I have a premiere for my
BMX brand we have a BMX DVD coming out
and I know I'm gonna have to be out of
the house until like at least 11 and I'm
trying to like steal myself in
preparation for that because being out
of the house until 11 just sounds kind
of [__] crazy to me at this point in
my life I just yeah but then at the same
time I'm talking to Jason Lee yesterday
and I'm realizing this [__] has
great relationships because he's still
in the club and he's he's still out here
he's into his 40s but he's still like
finessing those relationships on a
nightly basis which is something that I
have completely neglected and I should
really probably do more of it I've just
come to the point in my life where any
relationships I already have I I try to
water them you know like plants and I'm
not interested in
going out anymore so if I don't if if
unless it's somebody who I really [__]
with you know or like someone who like
I'm a fan of you know like
I don't care if it's album release party
I don't care I'm tired 2016. like there
was an album release party last night
that I would have went to if I'd have
known but I got hit up last minute like
Bia B is a homegirl like she's cool
right I [__] would be it but I was
already at the crib my wife just cooked
I'm like I already planned a bike ride
exactly yeah and I'm like damn and
especially with the kid thing because it
was like my kids waking me up at six in
the morning yeah my kid is waking me up
at six in the morning and it doesn't
matter if I go to bed at four in the
morning or it doesn't matter you're
getting up at six you're getting up and
it's like and especially like I have a
wife she she will take on all of that
responsibility of taking care of the
kids and everything but I don't feel
like that's fair for me to just put
everything on her and be like no I'm
sleeping a couple hours later just so
that I can like you know recover from
the fact that I had a fun night last
night because like 2016 if it was a
Friday night this was the era of like
underground warehouse shows in LA and
stuff and there would be like some
random [__] Soulja Boy show in a
warehouse and like the ham on everything
era and I would go and I would see
people I knew and I would stand around
and smoke weed and drink and probably
snort coke and do whatever and just meet
people and just like do this little like
friend collecting thing that you're
doing at a certain point in your life of
just me nice to see you everywhere yeah
yeah and I respect that and there's a
certain point in your career where you
have to do that but also like as soon as
I had a kid it was just like what the
[__] am I doing